[Music]
hi everyone judge andrew napolitano here
for judging freedom
today is thursday august 18 2022 it's
about five o'clock in the afternoon
here on the east coast of the united
states
uh this is our regular weekly interview
with dr joel wallach which is proving to
be
very popular
dr wallach is a neuropathic physician
who for his lifetime for his career
has caused people to use the the body's
own abilities combined with natural
sources to cure all sorts of ailments
today we're going to discuss diabetes
dr
uh wallach
offers for sale
different
supplements and vitamins to help the
body to cause the body
to cure itself of whatever ailments are
attacking it you can see what's
available at judginghealth.com dr
wallach's company youngevity
is partnering with judge and freedom
and you can reach all of his products at
the website which you see
on the lower part of your screen at
judging health dot com we'll talk about
the website in a few minutes dr welling
it's always a pleasure my my sir my dear
friend welcome back
uh to judging freedom
well
you're a great
national international person
of great experience and
everybody loves you and respects you
i'm just can't tell you what an honor it
is to be working with you oh thank you i
i
i buy a lot of newspapers each morning
and i was in this i live out in the
country i was in this little grocery
store that holds them for me each
morning and a woman came up to me and
said i can't thank you enough
for dr wallach
uh what he told me about arthritis i
went right to the website i got i forgot
what she told me she got
but she began to feel relief
within within days of her having
purchased it which was within hours of
her having
uh observed our last session together
which was on arthritis
so i was ecstatic to hear that and i i
trust it's um anecdote it's just
anecdotal but i trust many people feel
similarly in fact i know they do
um so let's start with today's subject
is diabetes
what is diabetes what causes it
how do you know if you have it
okay well the simple definition of
diabetes is you have high blood sugar
blood sugar is elevated
but it's not genetic it's not autoimmune
it's not caused by aging it's a simple
nutritional deficiency it's a simple
nutritional deficiency no matter how you
look at it
uh
99.9 percent of diabetes has type 2
diabetes
less than 1 of diabetes is type 1
diabetes which is a birth defect it's
not a genetic birth defect mama's
missing stuff when the beta cells are
being formed in the eyelids langerhan of
the embryonic pancreas she doesn't have
enough of that nutrition to create
enough
insulin and so the baby's born with type
one diabetes less than one percent of
americans have type 1 diabetes 99.9
are type 2 diabetics now when you're a
type of 2 diabetic
you lose 10 years your life instead of
your life expectancy being 75 like
everybody else's is 65. if you're a type
1 diabetic your life expectancy is 55
instead of
75. wow okay
and so
it pays to pay attention to the details
here and get rid of all the bad stuff to
maximize absorption and take the program
to make sure you get everything you need
now the problem we have your honor
is that these nutritional minerals do
not occur in a uniform blanket around
the crust of the earth they occur in
veins like gold and silver and you can
be eating the same recipe that your twin
brother twin sister is eating and they
live in pennsylvania and you live in
wyoming and you have
20 different diseases you're going to
all these doctors for and the one in
pennsylvania's not going to any doctor
doesn't have any diseases
because he or he might be getting 25 or
30 or 40 different minerals and you're
only getting three
okay and so that's the problem is it's
kind of depends on where you live and
what you eat and so forth so it's
imperative
to consciously take everything and that
way you know you're getting it you can
only guarantee
you're getting it if you take it and so
that's why we came up with these
programs
the basic program that everybody needs
to be on
um you know everybody
you know how many people put dirt from
texas in their car to save some money
that's only 10 cents a quart for dirt
from texas nobody does that they put oil
in their car
well you got to do the same way with
yourself don't treat your car better
than you're treating yourself
so i you know i like that healthy brain
and hard pack it has 215 nutrients and
it covers the waterfront so to speak and
you know take
one dose per hundred pounds of body
weight if you weigh 150 i'd go with two
doses
and
then also
uh you need to make sure you're taking
what we call the secret sauces we have
secret sauces for 600 different diseases
including diabetes before you get to the
secret sauces how would somebody if they
don't see a doctor regularly how would
somebody know that they have high blood
sugar my little chris is here there he
is come on get on the camera chris
he's half a german shepherd and a half
beagle but very very feisty two and a
half years old lovable okay
how would anyone know that they have
high blood sugar if they don't go to a
doctor and get their blood tested or
stated differently
what are the symptoms of diabetes okay
well your honor this is very very
very easy
uh one of the symptoms of type 2
diabetes is urinating a lot
okay you have high blood pressure you
cause you to urinate a lot
okay
and um if you get low blood sugar you
get headaches and dizziness and you want
to be sleepy and all that kind of stuff
you want to be driving if you have low
blood sugar you'll fall asleep and get
in a crash that's what causes a lot of
these crossing over the middle line uh
crashes okay as people have hypoglycemia
low blood sugar
and um
they fall asleep and cross the center
line and create an accident which can
kill people or themselves or major
damage and so on
but
the
how you can tell yourself everybody
should do this you should just give
yourself an examination at least once a
year you might want to do it once every
three months and you go to a pharmacy
without a prescription and you buy test
strips for sticking yourself in the
finger it'll tell you how to do it and
so forth it costs like a dollar thirty
per test
and then they also have
the test strip for urine and test your
urine see if there's any sugar in your
urine
okay if you have diabetes you're gonna
have sugar in your urine
and it's only cost like a buck 30 for
test strip okay it's not like it's
expensive you can do it yourself
and um again we have cds we have books
that tell you how to do all this you
know let's play doctor tells you how to
do that the book let's pray are there
are there other symptoms besides
frequent urination and is frequent
urination a symptom both in men and
women
the symptom in both men and women uh
when you when you have diabetes okay
that's that's one of the most common
symptoms okay you can have headaches and
all that kind of stuff but you're less
specific but you do need to
um say okay you know i better check my
blood sugar here and so
go to the pharmacy without a
prescription get the test strips either
for your
sugar stick your finger or for urine
okay
uh you pee in a cup and then to stick
the test strip down in that cup and and
in like 30 seconds it'll give you the
answer
very very quickly
and so this is not what
what causes high blood sugar is it a
diet
is it
no no it's not genetic it's a
nutritional deficiency say nutritional
deficiency and it depends on what you
eat
and what you're not getting in the food
you're eating okay if you're not
supplementing with these nutrients and
that's why we like the healthy brain and
heart pack because it contains these
nutrients that will prevent diabetes
it'll reverse diabetes
because it has these nutrients in them
they're very specific
okay i i love when people your honor
they say
oh i supplement every day really what do
you supplement with oh i take vitamin c
every day well what about the other 89
nutrients well my doctor said i can get
everything i need just by eating well
your doctor needs to have his license
taken away from him because that's not
true
okay now what happened well this goes
back to three o'clock in the afternoon
monday september 4th 1882 on pearl
street in new york city in the bluff
overlooking the construction of brooklyn
bridge when town assessed and pulled the
switch on the first commercial electric
drainage plant before we had
electricity your honor we had wood and
coal and
that kind of stuff and grandma would
take the ashes from the wood stove and
the fireplace in the fire pit
and and put the wood ashes and coal
ashes into the garden and we're putting
those minerals because the ashes were 98
minerals only two or three percent
carbon
okay
and the the carrots and the corn and the
um
uh
cucumbers and the tomatoes and
everything would suck up all those
minerals and you'd get your minerals by
eating those foods that were fertilized
with the wood ashes and the coal ashes
and then grandma but also put wood ashes
and coal ashes into your soup into your
cereal in the morning hot cereal
uh as a spice but also you were getting
the minerals that way well once we went
to electricity
the doctors didn't make up the
difference they said okay now we have to
replace the source of minerals you've
been using for thousands of years
okay and so now we have to give you
vitamins and minerals to take orally to
make up for what you're not getting your
food anymore because you have
electricity they never did that all
right so i'm scratching my head so i
love to burn
i have a lot of fireplaces in this old
home and i love to burn one of them all
the time in the in the wintertime
can i take the ashes and put them in
soup or in tomato sauce
yes you can and you can also put them in
your garden let's say you just have a
half
barrel sitting on the porch or something
like that you're growing tomatoes put
some of those wood ashes or coal ashes
into that
little garden you have on your porch and
so even people who live in an apartment
building can do that with a half a
barrel you know the tomatoes and
cucumbers and beans and
things like
green and red
bell peppers and stuff like that
fertilize them with those wood ashes
you're going to get minerals that way
now you don't know which ones you're
getting because you don't know which
minerals are in the wood but you know
there's minerals there so you still
should take consciously take the
minerals um the healthy random heart
pack and then if you have diabetes you
want to take the um let's see here you
want to take the
sweeties okay the sweeties take three of
those twice a day per hundred pounds of
body weight and just within days it'll
bring everything right into line
what what is the uh myth or maybe it's
not a myth so i i shouldn't label it
i'll let you label it what is the basis
for the belief
that eating sweets
produces diabetes
okay when you eat sweets your blood
sugar goes up
okay if you don't have the nutrients
necessary for your body to deal with the
sugar
you can't handle it so your blood sugar
goes up
okay but if you have all the nutrients
you need for all your biochemical
equipment to work properly
you can handle a little bit of sugar
because you have
your own
insulin in your pancreas okay your cells
will also burn
the sugar
if you have uh the
stuff available
but
it's kind of by gosh by golly you don't
know what minerals are in those wood
ashes because you don't know where the
wood came from that they burned or you
burned and so you don't know what's in
the soil there you have to have a soil
analysis or an analysis of the ashes to
know what's in there so it's kind of
like a plus when you take wood ashes
it's a plus
okay and so but if you take a healthy
blood sugar pack which is a healthy
start pack in the sweeties
uh that's our most economical way to do
that
but if you have other issues i'd go with
the healthy branded heart pack in this
and the sweeties okay so i have i have a
friend i'm not going to mention his name
um
72 year old male a college professor
who just had his uh one of his legs
removed below the knee
because of diabetes
now why did the doctors do that and how
did this dreadful situation come about
that the doctors wanted to and talked
him into
performing surgery as radical and
irreversible as the removal of half of
his leg
okay well what happens when you have a
constant
high levels of blood sugar
uh you get an inflammation in the lining
of your blood vessels
and you get plaque in your blood vessels
it's not it's not cholesterol that
causes plaque in your blood vessels it's
inflammation that's caused by high
levels of sugar
that kind of stuff
and so when you have high levels of
sugar
your blood vessels your arteries your
veins get the
the blockages
and you cut off the blood flow by
cutting my
blockages shutting off the blood flow
but if we had to put him on the ultimate
daily classic tablets
and gotten him on the sweeties i believe
we could have saved his leg
wow
even if he had open ulcers on his feet
and draining and all that kind of stuff
i believe we could have saved his leg if
you know he had done that
so he he uh
he stubbed his toe
by accident this was you know before the
diabetes was discovered and the toe
turned black
went to the doctor the doctor said you
have diabetes i'm not sure what else
they told him
but six months later he was having this
radical irreversible surgery
yeah okay well
you know when you get
symptoms like that he had blockages of
the arteries and veins in his feet and
when he stubbed his toe
he had some hemorrhage that's why his
foot turned black because he had
hemorrhage it was bruised
okay
and so so when you have bruising that's
caused by
hemorrhaging
and um
those are the sort of things you see
when you have
diabetes
isn't it isn't it malpractice
for his physicians
to have let the diabetes get so bad that
they had to cut his leg off rather than
suggesting
uh the the mineral treatment
that you just told us about well it
would have been ideal to do the mineral
treatment first
okay and also given the ultimate daily
classic tablets first to get the blood
flowing through the blocked arteries in
his legs and feet
and i believe it could have saved his
legs i mean we saved the legs and the
arms uh and hands and feet of so many
people in the world by just doing these
little simple things
uh but you know doctors get the tuition
money to keep their kids in college by
doing amputations
how many people have diabetes in the
country today
okay diabetes today in america
is um
37.3 million cases in the united states
37.3 million cases that's 11.3 percent
of our population here's the one that's
scary your honor we have 96 million
pre-diabetics in america that's just
about a third of our population
okay and it cost us 342 billion dollars
a year just to treat the symptoms of
diabetes not to prevent it or cure it
just to treat the symptoms just to lower
the blood sugar it cost us 342 billion
dollars a year
a cancer only costs 190
no 190 billion 190 billion dollars a
year uh it's about half
right so what does it mean to be a
pre-diabetic
okay a pre-diabetic is you have
your your blood sugars just on that line
where another couple of points should be
diagnosed as a diabetic so a
pre-diabetic instead of your blood sugar
being
um
65-70
it might be 80
something like that because you're
getting close to 100
so if a person is pre-diabetic are there
minerals to prescribe to river
at
judginghealth.com to reverse that
oh yeah absolutely they need to take the
healthy brain and heart pack for the
basic
need for all those 215 nutrients then
they need the sweeties i had him take
three of those twice a day
and they need to be taking um you know
measurements of their blood sugar and
their and their urine sugar you know
with these um little test strips that
they get from the pharmacy without a
prescription they only cost about 30
each i think they come in bottles of
three and five and ten and so forth very
easy again the cost of dealing with
these 96 million people with
pre-diabetes and 37.3 million people
with type 2 diabetes
has 342 billion dollars a year we spend
just to treat the symptoms
and
you know in these some of these other
countries
based on their population the
percentages are about the same if they
live on a
a diet that's based on
stuff
that countries are you know like
european countries canada united states
we're talking about the
the countries that uh are
very well
which they say uh laced when it comes to
finances and cash flow and stuff like
that
right um okay when you when you have
country with lots of money uh you're
going to see more diabetes
well
dr wallach some of this is terrifying
but it all is so helpful how i wish my
friend
had known of you and your good work
before the radical surgery that he had
and i hope people
watching and listening now will go to
judginghealth.com
uh we'll consult that's what
what the website looks like there are 5
uh
supplements there and there are people
to speak with on the phone as as you are
being guided through
the website
dr wallach it's always a pleasure thank
you very much we'll we'll talk to you
during the week so that we know what
you're going to talk about next week but
until that time all the best you my
friend
god bless you sir uh you are one of
god's greatest angels and we love you
and appreciate and respect you thank you
your honor right back at you thank you
judge napolitano
for judging health
and for judging freedom
[Music]
you